this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by my
supporters on patreon patreon also comes
with a bunch of different tiers
including extra content unedited
versions of podcasts and things like
outtakes and bloopers you also get ad
free versions on both video and audio
versions of the show and there are a
bunch of other tiers as well like you
can ask questions or you're first in
line to play a game with me every month
most importantly though the patreon
helps to support shows like this one so
huge thanks to all of our supporters on
patreon enjoy the show I think this well
I think this time I'm gonna call it now
and you know if this part makes into the
podcast I'm sure it'll be ironically
hilarious later like I'm gonna call it I
think I think you've set it up perfectly
this time I think we are we've done it
right as starters of the podcast
um we have we have done our jobs
properly it's only taken uh it's only
taken you know like a hundred tries but
well Alana didn't give us the chance to
shine until you know quite recently
we've only been able to start the
podcast a few times so like honestly as
a leader it's on her like it's on her
for not giving us the opportunity that's
fair reveal our true hidden depths she's
um yeah she's really holding us back
yeah exactly yeah I think we should it's
it's kind of a law on his attitude
though she's quite a quite a mean person
I think the coup that is brewing uh is
presentable we're in this moment I mean
powers
good you know continuing to support the
release of that uh show that we uh
talked about last time the Thai K rescue
um on Netflix now watch it without dub
it's great yes exactly
um I have a um
uh friend who has invested in a pretty
Burly home theater setup and he wanted
to watch it and because I hadn't been
able to see the final the true final
you know combo of sound design and the
proper mix especially you know in the
like 5-1 and Atmos mixes yeah
um of the last few episodes like I
attended the the final sound mix for the
last episode and I we had the screening
in a movie theater
um of the first two episodes
um so the third fourth fifth and third
fourth and fifth
um there were a few visual effects and
finalized things that I like I saw the
picture locked version but there's a few
little kind of things that I don't think
it's even fair to call them polish
because they're quite essential and
mandatory
um but uh but they're different from
fundamental edit
kind of choices you know picture lock
kind of things so there are a few little
things I hadn't seen so my
friend hosted uh Angela and I over at
his house to do like a binge of all six
episodes on Sunday that's great in like
a proper like Atmos he's got this crazy
projector that's like got warnings all
over it of if you look directly into it
while it's running you know you will you
will meet will overpower you you will
melt uh Raiders of the Lost dark style
for sure so anyway it was great to
um
to kind of properly watch it and an
interesting thing
um cropped up where every time the
episode ends
it starts the end credits and gives you
about three seconds to decide to opt in
before it just tosses you into the next
episode
and you know I recognize that Netflix
probably is in a continuous state of
tuning that you know like how long those
timeouts are going to be but I imagine
that's kind of irritating to watch like
a chunk of your work just kind of be
immediately disregarded well it was
funny because on the primary platform
yeah well exactly the the my friend ever
he he missed all six credits because
it's a pitch black theater and he has
like a little remote that's like a
little touch pad that controls the oh so
he was like he would like reach for it
but then you have to wake up the pad and
then tab over to the like it defaults
when the cursor comes up it defaults to
next episode to you know in case the
three seconds is too long you can
manually click to go to the next episode
um or tab to the left and watch the
credits and so and the funny thing was
we made the decision to write new music
for each credit it's not like a
repeating end credit piece it's yeah now
I think about I think I might have let
Netflix skip those
well it's all on the soundtrack album
but it is um it is a uh an interesting
album available to purchase it's it is
all my platforms of choice it's even on
bandcamp thanks to Netflix uh letting me
do that um but um but yeah it's
everywhere and
um uh there's tons of Music That's not
on the album because they wanted to keep
the album to about 90 minutes and we
wrote almost five hours of music but
um but uh in any case the point being
this idea that um the end credits like I
was fascinated by this notion that most
people
uh they they only do that I'm sure in
reaction to the fact that if it if it
automatically plays into the credits
they probably see a noticeable drop-off
of people that don't continue to the
next episode
people feel a sense of completion on
that and they yeah they might like I can
see the calculation of
um you're on the fence about whether to
keep going the credits play long enough
for you to go you know what I guess I'm
good for the day and you turn it off and
then life takes you know precedent and
then you forget about the show and you
never keep going I think it's more I
think it's more emotional I think it's
like when I watch a show and I'm allowed
to watch the end credits I feel like an
end point like it feels like a natural
ending it's not it's not that I'm sat
there looking at my watching oh I'm
gonna go and get on my day it's that I
have had a complete experience whereas
if you keep chopping off the experience
they're they're they're edging the
audience for lack of a better phrase
right that's the whole I think so
keeping you at that point of not
finishing I feel terrible about the
analogy I've walked no no no no it's
um
uh it is
it is like obviously the the show is the
thing that we're all in service of so I
don't begrudge anybody not watching the
uh ending credits you know it's one of
those that's that's one of those things
that ending credits are some combination
of there for these cinephiles slash to
fulfill contractual obligations
um and you know that it's not like other
than the the Pixar kind of let's stylize
the first half do you think but when you
think about like H like Peak HBO what
they did all of their or like how
important the credits were to like
you're watching like a dead wood and
every single episode has like a unique
beautiful piece of music with Susie of
Sopranos like all over the end stuff
like it yeah the end credits like I I
associate with like specifically on TV
like there's those that kind of era that
Golden Age whatever like the HBO drama
there was a lot of I guess more licensed
stuff than necessarily soundtrack
credits but like
um yeah Warrior as well like just that
kind of always having something
different every single ending I quite
like um but yeah I I remember breaking
down obviously but I always assume that
the reason Breaking Bad was doing that
was in part or in in or primarily
because
um there was so little score like that
it was pretty soft touch I mean it's
very effective music but it wasn't some
big musically driven shows pretty pretty
yeah before given for saying there was
no music
um so I think that it was sort of like
to help
to help kind of counter the his lack of
a voice in the the storytelling as an
overall thing he could he could that
would be he could make a statement yeah
because I'll never forget when they when
the show introduced the character it's
been so many years I don't remember his
name but the the kind of elderly guy who
never speaks and he's in the wheelchair
and he has the little bell that he Rings
yeah I remember the ending credits
starting with the sound of the bell and
then and then like the sound turning
backwards and be like and then became a
piece of music and it was clearly
designed for that episode and I thought
it was awesome but any case yeah I found
it I bet it's both I and probably more
than just those two things but the idea
that the emotional feeling of completion
as a demotivator to continue is probably
at work on some subset of the audience
and then there's the other subset where
um they are you know it's it's 11 30 at
night and you're going yay do I watch
one more or do I go to bed and if you
watch one more the odds for every
episode you watch the odds that you'll
keep going to the end of the season
probably go up whereas if you stop it
yeah well probably yeah
um I mean I don't know I certainly don't
know Netflix's user data I'm sure that's
locked in a vault of you know with like
nuclear codes you know like it's we see
it we see you're right though I can like
I can definitely with video games like I
If you look at like
um like all metrics of like people
completing games you're absolutely right
that basically if someone gets to like
halfway through a game chances are
they're gonna finish the game well our
numbers of people who get 50 through a
game are similar to what people who get
to 100 or 100 in terms of like
completing the game through not
necessarily like unlocking everything
yeah right yeah yeah seeing seeing end
credits on a game generally the 50 and
100 are similar enough to be
statistically kind of you know it makes
total sense well basically backing up
what you're saying yeah yeah I mean yeah
exactly and I I think I mean it happens
it's a perfectly understandable
psychological phenomenon and and you
know basically right like from uh like
entertainment Sun cost you know yeah
yeah absolutely and I and I get an
investment the um the calculation on
Netflix I share their their aim of what
would make more people watch the show so
I don't take it personally
uh that um the credits end up getting
squashed um it is interesting though
that it is it has narrowed to literally
not only is it quite literally under
five seconds I think it was three that
you have to respond but on top of that
the show doesn't have a big elaborate
main title sequence again in the
interest of Engagement I assume I it was
never again seconds right so I remember
genuinely yeah I was kind of watching it
and I was like getting into what you
were saying up and then boom you're into
the episode remember the first episode
be like really that's yeah because then
you'll have like a long version on like
the first episode and then you notice it
getting shorter as it goes on exactly
but I was genuinely I was doing the case
of The Simpsons all the time opening
couch gags have become like five minute
long short films that's just the main
title sequence expanding forever and
ever and ever but yeah this is you when
you'll I'll go well I was gonna say is
that it's funny to me that it gives you
the option to skip the opening when it
is quite literally a 15 second thing as
well that's all I was gonna say what
were we gonna ask I was gonna ask like
because I know for me it takes me
literally years to be able to like play
something I've directed and not be
immediately like spotting all the things
I would have done can you sit in that
wonderful you know cinematic we in your
mate Martin scorsese's home Cinema can
you sit and watch uh can you still watch
the can you say and watch an episode and
not be noticing all the things that you
would have liked to have tweaked or that
you feel like they maybe mess up on the
sound design or can you listen in as an
audience member yet well what's your
what's your kind of Half-Life on that
stuff can you can you when can you get
back to just enjoying something you
worked on it's really yeah I mean
there's it it's a bit of a spectrum I'm
definitely I like I'm like you probably
most everybody who makes stuff for a
living has a hard time consuming their
thing like I've spent the last 10 years
explaining to these
truly wonderful beautiful tear-eye
teary-eyed
Journey supporters I've had to spend 10
years explaining to them that I've never
been able to play the game the way they
have like I've never experienced that
that way and I I really can't I can see
it on an intellectual level like what
they're responding to and it evokes all
those conversations of it's when we try
to test [ __ ] right we get to make
anything we want exist but then we can
never enjoy it it's a proper little like
like that's a fable it's like uh
tragedy kind of yeah
no we're like Gods no we all like Gods
Austin we all like Gods like to be very
clear to the audience we are and
especially yeah I was going to say yeah
for those who have failed to make the
call time on today's uh taping uh
that's all I'm saying that's all I'm
saying God's they may arrive when they
want to but they know what time they're
meant to arrive yeah I like that that's
a good question T-shirt Gods God's uh
what'd you say gods are on time God's
can God sir Gods I think I was
paraphrasing Tolkien at that point yes
yeah no but he said it in a way stealing
from the best uh it's not truly in any
case so yeah I I occasionally work on
something that it's so good the the sum
of its parts managed to override my oh
like you're enjoying everyone else's
contribution yes so much that you don't
notice yours like I had tears in my eyes
watching this show on Sunday and it's
definitely not on account of my music
it's like in spite of that I'm able to
kind of you're enjoyable actors
appreciate the cinematography and also I
think in the case of the show knowing
that it's a true story and it's so
faithful to the true story I get really
wrapped up in this idea that you know
the the stuff that those people were
made of that are made of you know that
they that they Rose to the occasion uh
in in service of in MO in in the
overwhelming majority of cases a total
strangers just to try and help just to
just to be you know some small portion
or in some of the cases of like the
divers and people like that a major part
of it just the the volunteer nature of
it I get so moved by the kind of
humanism of that I might be being
ignorant of the approach because I've
obviously never worked in like TV or
film but like I I would assume don't you
when you're writing a cue you have the
the scene basically like maybe it's not
got the final so you've seen every
impactful moment of that show well I've
seen every frame whether it had music or
not many many times in this case
especially the emotions still maintained
because if you watch the same if you
watch the same sad movie 100 times it's
going to impact you less is it just
because of the true story aspect or is
it something about the Holistics in the
round as part of the whole I think it's
both but I do think the true nature of
it is
uh kind of a little bit of a cheat it's
like a shortcut to my emotional sort of
empathic nature
um but um
but I think that um I've had it I did a
movie a long time ago called Captain
which
um was is the world weirdly trivia about
that is the first ever Jordanian feature
film it was all shot mostly in Amman
Jordan and similar to this it's it's all
you know it's all local mostly
non-actors and it's not a true story
though but it has a very Fable almost
Spielberg kind of quality to it and I
watched that I mean that played at
Sundance and a million other festivals
and I ended up watching it probably in
excess of 20 times with audiences as
part of the festival like I traveled
around with the director it was the
first major film that I had ever done it
was first major really anything that had
any kind of life like that
um I did it right at the same time as
flow and you know Flo went online and
then I got to read online people's
reactions but film festivals gave you an
opportunity to sit with people while
they experienced the film which is truly
it's very nerve-wracking because
obviously if it's not Landing with them
you very much feel that it's like a
stand-up comic who's bombing or
something but this film was only
recently when I went to a games event
and one of our old games was there
playable and I had no idea going to this
event that the game was playable that
happened completely without me involved
and I just went and like stood and
watched people play it and there was one
guy who was explaining for five minutes
very loudly why he hated the game well I
stood kind of behind and I was listening
and I was like I was listening to this
kid and I was like I was agree with like
75 of what he was saying I was like
that's are you intentionally not a game
which game it was I would never publicly
like negatively talk about any of my old
games
um because they're all brilliant you
should pick them up inside yeah this
this one was this person was like
talking about it I was like yeah no
that's fair that's that's a valid uh
description
well I think I think most
um
sort of counterparts to your version
like Mo the other biffles of the world
who might that might have happened to I
think would have not resisted the
temptation to get in there and go well
here's the thing you're missing you
don't understand there's this oh like no
I get that you wouldn't do that but it
would have been uh interesting and
difficult to resist but yeah I don't
know it's a rare I mostly can't truly
enjoy these things I remember I think
the only game that I ever actually
played
as like a player in Earnest like where I
got really into the systems of it and
and and and and played like as if I had
no attachment to it was the banner Saga
Trilogy those for whatever reason that's
just as a genre of game right in my
sweet spot I just really loved the
pacing I love the art style and again
it's like a little hard for me to kind
of not get distracted by all the things
I wish I could change or that you know I
realized oh I'm so much better or I'll
just sit there going I don't know why I
did this like I'll I'll just I'll have
to try to I'll sit there distracted
trying to remember why I did this versus
that and etc etc most games are it's
just too that that inner voice is too
loud to really kind of play the game as
a as a normal person
and um but for whatever reason the
better song I played through I think
twice uh which is you know non-trivial
number of hours
uh for a thing that I had already played
probably 200 hours in play testing
before the game even shipped so yeah it
is you would think it would get totally
burned I mentioned that Captain because
that film would make me cry
every time I watched it with an audience
it's just such a beautiful film and the
lead actor Nadeem sawalha you know Julia
sawalha she's kind of famous in the UK
she's yes yeah yeah
um comic actor yeah she did the voice of
the the lead actress voice in Chicken
Run opposition Mel Gibson
um and a bunch of other TV I think her
father is this kind of wonderful Elder
Statesman Jordanian British actor who
among other things got thrown out of a
window by Jaws in one of the Bond films
and he was Sean Connery's sidekick in
the win in the lion he plays the title
character Captain Abu right
um and uh just amazing I mean he should
have been nominated for an Oscar I mean
it was like it's one of those
performances where he's just so good
he's like he's like the grandpa you just
desperately want you know uh and it's
just yeah what a great film that was and
this this show kind of brought back some
of that where it's just there's such a
humanism to it it's such a it's such a
it's such a story of a reflection of
like the best we can be as a as a people
as a as a species that as someone who is
definitely wired towards optimism and a
kind of happy spin on the world it kind
of TAPS into a nerve that sort of
overwhelms me I'm a cynic but I
definitely enjoy that my fiction for
sure it's nice uh brutal
yeah exactly it's a true story it's kind
of above my cynicism which I liked I I
enjoyed watching as well and it felt I
think as well though they they
definitely
um
they definitely
addressed the cynic in the audience like
it definitely it was a show didn't shy
away from showing the imperfection which
only made you know the heroism of the
characters who were heroic better like
they were they weren't they weren't
creating kind of cartoony villains but
there was lots of like apathy and people
not bothering and and kind of that kind
of stuff which definitely kind of
grounded it for me yeah
are people wonderful I think I probably
would have tuned out yeah it's not no
yeah it's not I mean even even like one
of the boys his he's desperate to get
away from his parents and he um
uh like that's like a recurring Motif in
the show that that he's was upset or
especially in the first episode that
he's upset with the coach for telling
the parents about the game because then
they show up and he was just hoping to
have one day free of their fighting and
they're bickering like it's a very kind
of unpleasant household for him and
um that's true like when we got to go
and meet the boys the parents dosed that
that particular kid's parents did not
come that night because they knew they I
think they probably also were not too
happy with Netflix at their accurate
portrayal on a [ __ ] for 200 million
people to see and uh so it's an
interesting it's an interesting thing
that they they definitely sought realism
and accuracy over the kind of
rose-colored thing all that said you
guys were very indulgent letting me uh
go on about it last time um and so I
will I will happily pivot away from it
to not be overly austin-centric but it
does it the show raised a question that
I've been dying to ask you guys about
um which we only kind of tapped at the
very end of uh this this notion of
titles because
um I think I mentioned I don't remember
if I said this out loud or if I was just
thinking of it that when I was scoring
it I was sure that taike rescue was like
the project code name I didn't think
they would actually ship with that name
because it just seemed like that's not a
that's not a name but like as as I
zoomed out I realized well
I understand
the notion of like just just explaining
the premise in the name and I started
thinking I mean I guess is there any
difference between that and death Loop
like that's that's actually a really
dumb name uh but but maybe that's the
genius you know what I mean I I think I
get I get I get a little lost in the
weeds and like pretentious about
aspiring to an Elegance you know like
like they I remember the show run at one
point saying you know he thought what if
we called it you know like the boys and
the cave or something and it's like
would would fewer people watch the boys
in the cave especially knowing that
there was a real thing that happened and
that this is a telling of that real
thing versus just Tire see I liked the
Ron Howard movies titled 13 lives that's
a great name
um but you know it's maybe less could be
a horror movie could be a it could be
about one and a half cats uh actually
what is it nine lives yeah not quite
um not quite but that's okay yeah so I
was curious your take on this because
like for example subsurface circular
that's a title that has the opposite
problem arguably but I'm curious if your
data reflects that or how you think
about this because you know what's that
question it's a fair question it's an
argument we have every single time
probably every production ever like
probably every game unless it's unless
it's you know
Assassin's Creed or something where
they're inheriting the name and they
know that people are going to know what
that means and they have that Advantage
going for them but it just made me
realize I thought even Star Trek is a
very silly name like it is it's sort of
it it is somehow comes across as elegant
but it almost feels like a trick because
when you sit there and really analyze it
head on you go is it actually a good
name I don't know Star Wars like maybe
they are actually pretty equal in their
bluntness to tiger or like what was the
um money Heist you know the like I just
I look at it I go yeah I don't know I
but I was curious yeah what's your
what's your kind of Ideal versus then
the compromise that is required of
what I could normally so normally it's
an it normally comes down to with most
of our games I believe and I'm probably
wrong because everyone always takes
credit for every idea I probably I think
I've come up with the title of every
game we've done I'm sure there's I'm
sure I'm wrong you did coin the term
Tron so yes well so the Tron thing is
very interesting I don't know if I can
tell the story of the name on the show
actually okay I will tell you offline
the story of the name on Tron identity
because that's a fun one but the um
let's try to let's hold like a note that
we can be coming in at the edit point of
like so anyway you were saying that was
a great story
um yeah no the um the so generally it's
an argument or a a discussion between my
me and my business partner Alexander we
generally we generally fall on two sides
so I'm I tend to be the one who wants a
Vibe or like a story thing and he's
usually the one who's in frankly being
the voice of reason and going you have
to kind of tell people what the thing is
um and and usually I would say he
indulges me with the titles and most of
our titles are a bit more esoteric I
think Solitaire conspiracy is a good
example of one that he totally won
because he just literally said to me
it's uh like early on in the process
like there you can't this is a solitaire
game and you have to tell the audience
who wants to play a solitaire game this
is a solitaire game and then my reaction
to that was wrong [ __ ] you I'm gonna
make the bad guy of this game called
Solitaire and it's gonna be a conspiracy
that he's triggering sort of games
conspiracy so it's going to be a story
and for me I like that I like I
definitely like a name I didn't realize
that's where that kid like you were out
maneuvering the voice of reason
basically like I well because I like I
one thing I really like is like uh puns
or like secondary meanings in titles I
think a title for sure part of it is to
get people in the door but parties tend
to be remembered long enough for you to
for them to like yeah recommend it to a
couple mates or whatever so like
definitely with like with the circular
game subsurface circular is
intentionally like a phrase that's
interesting and an interesting kind of
phrase like I just it sticks in your
brain in a way that like train train
story probably wouldn't train dialogue
yeah and then what was fun was then
um when we decided to make like a game
that was in a similar vein to that
quarantine circular works but then we
had the problem because we knew you guys
making about quarantine but we had no
there was no Circle involved so we had
to again kind of backwards narrative
from there so there's a circle that the
aliens in in that game that you're okay
that they can't move out of so there was
a weird kind of back pack back I think
the other thing with my names for a very
long time was they were deliberately on
some level I always chose names based on
the main fund but it was also me trying
to take the piss out of a friend of mine
um uh Rami you know you know around me
yeah
um he um he took the piss out of me for
Thomas Was Alone and said like that game
would have sold like five times the
units if you've just called it like
rectangle Adventures like Thomas Was
Alone is such a pretentious it implies
that it's a very sad game people still
think Thomas Was Alone as like a a moody
depressing game rather than hopefully
what it is which is a fun joyful game
um
I mean it's the game has it has a kind
of a kind of a very British sense of
humor and his his joke was always like
you should have just called it a
rectangle adventure and he was like it's
so so pretentious to like to do that and
I was like okay from now on
and it's gonna blow your mind Austin
this is the are you ready for a uh like
a like end of uh Usual Suspects moment
from that point I'm gonna get my coffee
cup ready to drop
from that point on every name of every
game I've done since has directly
referenced shapes
that's hilarious so you've got the
circular games volume
um uh
Solitaire conspiracy we was the one
you're basically Mark Smith before that
you are shape you are talking with
always a shape reference
Zuckerberg at the end of The Social
Network where he's repeatedly checking
the friend request status uh yeah yeah
you're never gonna let this go Romney's
gonna like have forgotten he'll like
have moved on in life and doesn't even
know who you are anymore and you're like
no he loves it he loves it he sends me
every time we announce the game you'd
get a little like a DM or next time I
saw him he'd kind of you've done it
again but I guess you like because it
was just every single time I guess this
latest one has to break that uh pattern
then well Solitaire conspiracy was the
one where it was like no well I guess
the last two then
yeah Salt Lake conspiracy was the moment
where like we were trying to come up
with the title and I I was the one who
said like I can't keep naming my games
just about you know a joke with an old
friend I've been making for like nine
years this is bad this this very clearly
should be called Solitaire and we'll
work our name and then obviously with
Tron that's obviously a decision that's
not just mine so therefore yeah sure
it's gonna obviously move on from that
that idea
um have you ever opted out of a game
like has has can you think of an example
of not playing one because the title
didn't grab you and then later somebody
said oh it's this and you went oh it's
that
or maybe a movie is a better question
because you probably have your ear to
the ground game wise that it would be
hard to catch you kind of yeah games it
would be hard to get past me
um
which I think do you have one
I have I feel like I kind of
um I mean I have I still haven't watched
money Heist but that was one where when
I heard the name I was convinced that
must surely be some like
Netflix equivalent of a straight to DVD
you know like Ocean's 11 knockoff or
something you know how like you have the
Walmart DVD movies like I thought it
must surely be that and and then I've
been led to believe that it's actually
this amazing show uh I've still never
seen it because again actually you're
absolutely right I did the same thing I
was like almost be like a knockoff or
reality TV show or something yeah but
apparently it's really dominating clever
and yeah and one that similarly the name
was it's funny because I'm I think I'm
wired the same as you I much prefer some
slightly arguably pretentious hopefully
elegant or poetic title for things it's
fine the best point the audience knows
the podcast they're listening to it's
true I I so I I I like those kinds of
um
even though you know like what could be
more ridiculous than calling a walking
to the mountain game Journey like I you
know it's it's not like my career isn't
littered with like abzu there's a more
interesting kind of you know oh what is
that you know but it asks a question
that it oh my God to answer
like genuinely I think absu was one
where I was like
where I thought it was I can't remember
what I thought it was but I absolutely I
didn't know what that was until much
later but yeah I think I think but it
can go both ways right like once you
know what it is that's a very memorable
title and the same the way that Thomas
Was Alone now that I know what it is uh
yeah it's not a recognizable element
that's the same with subsurface circle
like those are names that you kind of do
keep hold of
um but the um yeah I don't know I I I
oscillate because I think and that's one
of the many reasons me and my business
partner have kind of done okay over the
decade is we generally find our we find
ourselves respectfully on the opposite
sides of a lot of arguments and
therefore we kind of end up in
interesting places and I think that's
that's um that's worked out well so yeah
with um with Tron obviously you know
there's lots more people in the room but
I'm really I really like the name
identity a lot I think that's I think it
suits the game it works on like three or
four levels we want the game's about and
identity discs and solving a mystery
which has an identity and people like
there's lots of like interesting
things that works but it doesn't tell
you anything about the game like for
sure it doesn't like tell you in terms
of like if you're looking for what the
genre of that game is
the the interesting thing with that as
well was identity suits
it feels like Legacy you know if it's it
fits with kind of the kinds of words
that have been subtitles and things
before oh yeah you've got Evolution
Uprising uh Legacy like they're you know
there's a it feels identity yeah it kind
of has an intuitive pattern camaraderie
with those
I think one that that I uh initially
camaraderie would be a good name
um Tron camaraderie it's the romantic
comedy uh that's the remote
um the um I I almost didn't watch
um or I should say I was slow to the
party on White Lotus on HBO
because that was one where I assume it
had for whatever reason something about
the name White Lotus felt like it was a
serial killer show
and I don't know why I have no argument
for that it just had that like you know
those novels of like uh Along came a
spider and like there was something
about the kind of almost fairy tale
sounding uh or Parable sounding name
that made me just come to assumptions
and then I see people raving about it
and I'm like it's probably just a very
good serial killer show and then at some
point somebody said it's not it's not
that or no it was it I was just skimming
through HBO and it showed up and I saw
that it was tagged as being a comedy
above all and that made me go what wait
what and then I watched it and like
everyone else afterward was just like
holy [ __ ] this is amazing
unbelievable storytelling I couldn't
finish it I found it so because it was
so good basically yeah I got so like
you're that kind of nervous energy but
it exists around yeah like I just
couldn't similar it was similar to the
kind of the the great last of us to
debacle like there's a certain kind of
like nervous I'm just onboarding social
anxiety I just can't take it because it
was too it was too good like I just got
too freaked out by the kind of how awful
everyone was and stuff I just couldn't
deal with it that's so funny I don't
know that I've ever I've ever uh not
watched something on account of that but
it's one of those where I mean I wonder
I'm very susceptible Mike like to to
like awkward situations or like um I
yeah I definitely have like a
physiological reactions like um what's
the what was the um uncut gems oh I
haven't seen you in Lee it's amazing
film but like by the end of it I felt
hungover like I felt broken by see that
and there's a good that's one where it's
good it's not obvious what the what it's
about it's it's it's a fun comedy it's
very chill yeah he's he goes on a wacky
adventure uncut gems creates the
presumption of a heist uh film when I
hear a title like that like it just
feels like
it feels like you know it's like
unmarked 20s like it feels like
something that a would a line that would
come up in a inside job or Ocean's 11
type or inside man
um uh you know kind of thing anyway it's
one of the and you know people you know
what's interesting
sorry what you made me think about with
that sorry apologies yes the other
aspect of naming things which is really
tricky so coming up with names really
tricky the other thing though is usually
if you're making something with a group
of people there's lots of people in the
room
and the basically any name you can come
up with there is a very easy dismissal
of and you end up getting into that Loop
of like people coming up with very good
ideas and then some like uncut gems for
example coming up as like an idea in a
room and someone else saying ah it
sounds like a heist movie and they're
not wrong
but there is that criticism of literally
any name you come up with except for
Thai cave rescue like there is there is
no there is in even that like obviously
you you mentioned like it didn't sound
like it was as interesting maybe as it
could be to you like there's it's a
really interesting Loop you get caught
in half of the reason coming up with
names is difficult is because coming up
with names is difficult but the other
half is that criticizing a name is very
easy yeah so there's kind of an
interesting kind of like and I've been
in those kind of brainstormers many
times for like the names of games the
names of game companies when I've been
at kind of companies that are startups
or the name you know just any naming
conversation is really tricky
um yeah because of that as well it is of
ideas lots of shoot Downs kind of
oscillating between each other
it is and someone just has to go we're
doing that one right yeah you need you
need to just that well that's the thing
like
I don't begrudge the name Thai cave
rescue it's one that I would never have
chosen but I probably would have made a
title that fewer people watched because
like you said the voice of reason goes
let's explain very clearly what this is
um and you know a great name
you know the best name is one that can
do it all Jurassic Park you know like
it's not without its Elegance but it
also is pretty obvious like you you
could make it largely dinosaurs from the
Cretaceous well exactly yes there's like
two species of that movie of that for
Jurassic it has a 12 year old that
really annoyed me yeah I was definitely
I I was I was the nerd who was so
overwhelmingly happy about the movie
that I let that one go but I was
definitely the nerd that was keenly
aware I it's funny I remember reading
actually not that long ago somebody made
the point that
um
that it was like a T-Rex and a stegosaur
a T-Rex was closer in time to an iPhone
than to the stegosaur
um and it's wild to think how long that
period was like it is how irrelevant
these talking monkeys are well that's
the thing like anything remotely human
passed a hundred thousand years ago
starts to become at best highly
debatable
um also we're not monkeys we're Apes I
just want to get ahead of that comment
in the in the comments yeah okay
everyone can stand down all my all my uh
all my evolutionary biology fam uh I
know you're there
they have opinions someone else is going
to correct that actually it's not
actually it doesn't matter it's fine the
great apes uh no that's my understanding
is that we are that that we are a subset
of the the Apes
larger the larger you know I can't
remember where in the
classic hierarchy we're the best states
oh clear I think we can all agree we
could we could shoot them that just
proves we're better uh you know we've
got we've got we've got uh technology on
our side so you know you're so cool
to think of you [ __ ]
oh I'm all about I'm all about the
racking up the clippable moments that uh
will eventually lead to my destruction
yes nothing's gonna drop me all women
look the same
um do you want to write a score for a
dinosaur game one day I really want to
do a dinosaur game one oh I know it's
funny where it's I'm up two minds on
that
um because of course I I would have said
the same going into an aliens game uh so
it's an interesting like the bar is
basically impossibly high so I'm not
saying do a Jurassic Park game because
there you just got to play the hits I
mean like a dinosaur but that's the
thing any dinosaur game is going unless
it's some really different take on a
dino like it's like you know it's like a
Tekken game that you're due with metal
music or something like let's say it's
something that you want to go like
really Against the Grain but if you're
if you're remotely in that let's try to
capture the Majesty what's the Jurassic
Park fighting game whether you literally
could play a T-Rex beating up a raptor
probably
I remember the Sega CD Jurassic Park
game where you play you play like a like
a mercenary who has to go gather the
eggs
um and it's like one of those sort of
Quasi FMV s uh Sega CD games and and it
had music that could not have been more
undressic Park like I'll never forget
that like
when you would be traveling across the
island and it's showing you these time
lapses of of a car driving and it's one
of those games that when I was a kid
Jurassic Park warp off Google at some
point nice literally it's a fighting
game dinosaurs yeah
um yeah so yeah I guess yeah you're
right you're you're walking in the
footsteps of giants with the with the
Giants like it's quite literally one of
the greatest scores and so if you want
to go the Majesty route you're competing
with I mean even like jakeino's Jurassic
world scores can't measure up to
Jurassic Park and like and when he needs
to he goes back to the well yeah and
he's no slouch and and it's not like he
doesn't have every kind of you know it's
all the same musicians even recording
these scores so it's like no but yeah
he's like he he knows he's a cover band
on that score he knows he's there to
play the song that's yeah I think that's
probably up he knows Fair way to put it
I mean in a negative way I'm a massive
giochino fan I prefer his Star Trek
stuff just because I think he he carved
his own path out a bit more with that
but like but yeah there are definitely
more different from other Star Trek
scores than Jurassic world is relative
to the John Williams scores but
in any case so like a dinosaur game I
mean look I I I I like for me
professionally the macro goal is always
just where somewhere I haven't been
what's a new thing that I haven't tried
um and so you know dinosaur game not
done that with as many feathers exactly
allowed to do
I remember going to see The Walking with
Dinosaurs live show where they have the
giant animatronic dinosaurs they're huge
I mean it's like basically you know life
to scale animatronics and it was one of
the most impressive things I've ever
seen and and that uh that had a big
bombastic Orchestra score they were
piping through the speakers I remember
the the BBC Walking with Dinosaurs was
done by Paul Leonard Morgan
the show had a good score right like the
the that's Paul he's he's very good
um he was one of the trio who did
cyberpunk 2077 but he he mostly does
film and TV which is good by the way I
just started that at the weekend I was I
I went I was I very much only heard the
negative stuff about Cyclone going and
cyberpunk now it's a really good game I
just saw the show they recently hit 20
million units or something like even
with all the refunds from the launch
um they were wildly popular or wildly
profitable uh uh you know even despite
you know having one of the most brutal
launches they just they just put out
some updates or whatever but like the
version I'm playing is like a solid kind
of first person RPG in the tradition of
like a Deus Ex or um I I remember trying
it on my PS4 I didn't have a PS5 yet and
it it couldn't quite
I definitely saw why people were so
incensed that it had shipped on PS4 but
even though I was like well so few
people have PS5 so that would be
ridiculous you know plus they've been
developing it for a million years like
it's not like it's native to PS5
um so it struck me as an intuitive thing
that it would come out on both even
though I I got the outrage outrage is
too strong I don't get being outraged
about this game doesn't work great
although I do recognize that you know
comparatively small investment I guess
uh to buy it and if I'm spending if I'm
only doing a purchase of that scale once
per year and it's a game that doesn't
work on my system but that's where I
just would get a refund and move on with
my life I guess
um not necessarily make sure that my
pitchforks were freshly filed and and
sharpened and but that's you all so
that's that's the Austin way we can't
expect the internet to live up to Austin
standards but yeah no on PS5 playing
that opening
like I was genuinely really impressed
with it I think as well there's another
good example of a title that's like
like its title is its genre like it's am
I right in saying that's because
the term the term predates the because
cyberpunk obviously was like a
role-playing game that like a tabletop
role playing game like that that that
came after like snow crash and stuff
right or did they did the cyberpunk the
tabletop game originate the word the the
phrase it's actually a great question
yeah yeah BR Alana are Alana Google uh
and feels like probably it's from Snow
Crash most of these things are from Snow
Crash but I will just double check yeah
I had just assumed that that
you know
uh they'd not
coin the terms certainly well that's why
I think I think the genre because like
you know Philip K Dick's stuff like
there's lots of stuff going back before
but I'm wondering did they actually like
we call that now cyberpunk but whether
they did but did yeah when was the term
like would Ridley Scott have known that
term
you know in exactly did he sit down on
doing a cyberpunk I am right yeah oh
he's oh his narration on blade right
I've talked about that on the show I
[ __ ] love it
um where's the bear with me talk among
yourself
yes
yourself
um
yeah anyway it's I I'm I'm endlessly
fascinated by the the notion of of uh oh
it was just it was sorry I got it 1980
it was a short story there was a short
story called cyberpunk which came out in
1980
um
so yeah the and Blade Runner came out
two years later so there's a chance
Ridley Scott didn't know that so that
was probably the term probably hadn't
locked into that right probably really
Scott didn't say the word cyberpunk
while directing well that also means
that like Philip Philip K Ducks uh
writing would have substantially
predated
uh the term then uh one of my favorite
things is creative people revealing how
haphazard the creative processes and
things that would subsequently become
like keystones so this is from the
Wikipedia page for cyberpunk uh befk
who's the guy who coined the name says
he made two lists of words
uh uh the one for technology and one for
troublemakers uh an experimenting for
combining them variously into compound
words consciously attempting to coin the
term that Encompass both Punk attitudes
and high technology
like it's like that's how that's like
that's like that's how I do it that's
like yeah that's like the algorithmic
you know the sort of like that's the AI
generated just like optimize for we
always want to assume that these big
cultural choices were made by like
photogeniuses who sat down it's like no
the guy had a deadline and he had to
name his short story for a magazine and
he just wrote down a list of cyber
digital computer tech and that's Punk
naughty Robin Hood funny well he landed
on a good one his process clearly worked
it's an incredibly evocative term
um it that's so funny that's like John
Williams uh is reported to have tried
something like 300 different five note
combinations before coming up with it
from Close Encounters uh knowing that
knowing they wanted five notes but just
like systematically going through you
know okay
no no no no no no no no like like just
another after another afternoon don't
you find like that just gives you
permission like that just basically says
that the people we look up to were not
significantly smarter than we are they
and I say that with the utmost respect
like they were smarter than we are but
like excessively small like on our level
I love that whenever I find something
like that how about something I love I
find that so empowering just of like oh
you know Ridley Scott again that
commentary which everyone should listen
to like he's just he he's talking over
Blade Runner he's just saying oh we did
that because we had that thing that day
or I saw awesome rain I thought that was
a cool idea and it's like and you hear
that as someone who makes stuff and and
it's exactly the same thought process
you go through and you're like okay I'm
on the right track
like this is good like I remember
watching
um
I remember watching a few years ago with
some Milestone like 10 years ago with
some Milestone anniversary of one of the
Back to the Future films
um it might have been 2014 actually
which would have been I guess like the
30th anniversary of uh of the first film
it wasn't at 84 is it 84. I think so
something like somewhere around there
they did a screening at one of the
theaters
um in Hollywood where they did like a
triple feature and some of the cast
would come out and do q a between like
Leah Thomas came out and and a couple of
Christopher Lloyd might have been there
um a couple of producers that kind of
thing and and um
so I hadn't watched those films really
since I was a kid
um and I saw him a bunch as a kid so I
knew them well but it had been a while
and seeing them as a as a triple feature
it was one of those where it made me
really appreciate that all three are
quite magnificent but the first one is
like Perfection I mean it really it's
one of those films that transcends
filmmaking and and and and to your point
about
like
the skill and the talent of of even the
greatest is on some level within our
reach in the sense that
I remember giving this overwhelming
impression watching Back to Future again
through a kind of more mature more
analytic set of eyes and just marveling
at it all the more and appreciating the
achievement of it all the more but it
also struck me as
this is a film that they didn't really
make it's a film that happened while
they were at their desk and then they
got to say they made it because
technically semantically they made it
but they then went and made the other
ones and they didn't quite add up and I
don't think that they did anything
lesser themselves sometimes it's like
the universe just kind of smiles on you
and this thing Sparks in front of you in
a way that you can't account for and it
to me that's the reassurance isn't gonna
work as well right because you're trying
to recapture Lighting in a bottle it's
um I think it's but it also shows that
it's my key that nobody knows what
they're doing as like an ethos of like
all creative work is everyone's figuring
it out everyone that's exactly that's
the thing it makes you realize they
actually don't have some like yes
they're very talented they're very smart
very creative but they don't have some
like Supernatural thing that is true
fundamentally Beyond any of the rest of
us like they are showing the next
problem they're just fixing the next
thing that comes up on their desk yeah
exactly and it's so there was something
about that and just sort of there's it's
like oddly comforting to know that yes
it's a perfect film and we should all be
so lucky to work on something half this
quality but it's not like they did
something beyond our imagination to
comprehend uh skill wise or talent wise
that's the thing that that it all left
me with that and I realized you know
that's part of what makes I think
Spielberg's career so unbelievable that
that
kind of conspiracy of the universe all
working perfectly to his favor to have
happened as many times like I would
argue Jaws you know E.T Jurassic Park
Saving Private Ryan Schindler's List AI
um
um uh probably
for sure uh Raiders of the Lost Ark but
I actually prefer Last Crusade even more
so I would say both of those films in
that same most people are lucky to have
one film of the of that like it's
perfect it's it's actually perfect
um he might be a genius like genuinely
him and like James Cameron as well you
know like Cameron is also like a freak
of nature yeah like he he actually I'm
sure he's awful to work with but he's
right did you hear the story about the
crew on the abyss had t-shirts made that
said the abuse
um that they like the crew all like had
those yeah there's some very there's
some very uh uh less than flattering
stories uh I remember what was it I was
watching the movies that made us I think
uh on Netflix about I think it was
aliens and how he was shooting in the UK
and he hated it because they took T like
High T at four o'clock and it drove
there's a really good doc yeah there's a
really good documentary that was that
came out I think second movie on DVD I
think it's like on YouTube and stuff now
it's like a two hour documentary and I
would genuine the alien documentaries
that came out it was the quadrilogy
wreck set just had these massive amazing
documentaries and yeah the the that one
I came Cameron strikes me as someone who
would have no problem with everyone
hating him though so like oh yeah I
found it on YouTube I found an interview
with James Horner from only a couple
years after aliens where uh and it was
one of those where he was speaking to a
classroom full of students at UCLA and
this was 1991 92 this is before the era
where you just have to assume that
whatever you're saying is going to get
recorded and put on the internet like he
was speaking very candidly because it
was theoretically a classroom full of
UCLA students in the early 90s how would
but the teacher had put a little camera
on a tripod and was just like ambiently
recording it for the archives I've been
caught out by similar myself
um and um and it's a really fascinating
discussion
um and it's but it's in the pretty
recent after like two or three years
after aliens and well before Titanic in
this window of time where Cam Horner
openly says like after his experience of
working with Cameron on Aliens he he
doesn't even want to talk to Cameron
anymore he had he had something like two
weeks to score that film and again
that's in that documentary you should
watch it I think you'd enjoy it uh yeah
I'm amazed I haven't I haven't actually
seen them I remember getting that
quadrilogy box coming back when back
when uh when documentaries were like
able to be honest about production
process which I don't feel is the case
anymore so much but you know for the
reason you're saying that like just
everyone's way too connected it is yeah
he was openly against him and then
obviously goes back and works on later
stuff with him yeah well that was the
thing is he goes he goes he basically is
like I think he's the best he goes I
think uh he goes he goes he goes there's
certain kinds of directors that give you
feedback or he said I can't remember
exactly a phrase it but it's something
very close to you there are some kinds
of directors that give you feedback and
then there's other kinds of directors
that 10 days after you started writing
the score and you're now standing in
front of a 90-piece Orchestra will say
to you in front of said 90 piece
Orchestra this queue is total [ __ ]
and he was like I'm not interested in
working with the latter type of director
anymore so you know some comment like it
makes it funnily clear that that Cameron
he didn't feel like the feedback was
particularly
um you know helpful and he even says I
think you should just feel lucky that
there's any score at all because I
basically had to kill myself to get this
thing in front of the orchestra and of
course this ended up being like a
classic that's like oscar-nominated you
know the whole Bishops Escape queue is
like one of those that everybody knows
you can always hear when it's been used
as a temp score and stuff because you
can hear people sort of not so subtly
ripping it off and so anyway they of
course apparently it was Horner scored a
Braveheart for Mel Gibson that Cameron
was just so in love with that he called
him and basically did what it take to
bury the hatchet to in order to get
Horner for Titanic because he just said
no one else can write the score that I
know this needs for Titanic and and he
got you know an oscar-winning score out
of him for that and then of course
subsequently on uh they they returned to
it on Avatar
um but um in any case yeah I I uh uh
apropos nothing
but sort of related I've Angela
discovered on Netflix a show called prop
culture have you heard of this
I think that's a it's a Disney plus
thing right because I think there's a
trumpet it's on Netflix there is a Tron
episode but it's on Netflix
oh is it I think over here it's on
Disney interesting Disney plus sometimes
things are different yeah it because
it's it's not it's not Disney
exclusively property well actually no I
don't think so although ironically the
only other one I can remember watching
was Who Framed Roger Rabbit
um but uh anyway anyway yeah sorry it's
so good though and I think you would
really really love it and there was
something again this is apropos nothing
I'm making a total left turn
um but though that said prop culture
excellent title
um the uh the uh the show is about this
guy who's like a big time collector
who's just going and tracking down rare
artifacts and things from from movies
and and he owns a lot he has a huge
collection of of rare you know and at
some of them it's like there was one
where here was a newspaper uh that was
on Bob Hoskins desk in Who Framed Roger
Rabbit like in a scene like it's like if
you look at frame 3017 there's the paper
like it's one of the he owns those kinds
of but he goes around to these prop
makers and into the various Studio
archives and they show a scene you
remember in that movie there's a bit
where Roger Rabbit shoots through the
window and leaves like the rabbit shaped
hole in the blinds yeah yeah they show
them the the like the prop used to
create that effect because obviously
everything was all done practically and
then animators hand Drew on each frame
of the footage to add the 2D animation
into the the live action and so
um which itself is insane
um and it just never happened anymore oh
it's so tedious
um and so the the uh they showed how the
the blinds they had the artists draw
Rogers outline in like the shape they
wanted to leave behind then they had to
do these laser cutting to get a very
very precise you know to cut out all the
little fragments of slats filling out
the shape and then carefully gently glue
them back in and attach wires to them it
was a wire gag like you would use for a
stunt like stunt fighting but wires
attached to each individual thing and
and then you pull the switch and it
Yanks the the thing backward uh into the
into the window basically and I love
that they did it in one take they
basically they shot it you'd have to
yeah that was and apparently the guy
they hired that I mentioned on the show
he's famous as being like the you know
like one take Johnny or whatever like
he's just he's got this track record
um but watch that one and watch The
Nightmare Before Christmas because the
something that they made me realize that
I can't believe I've never noticed about
Nightmare Before Christmas was obviously
stop motion is as tedious as filmmaking
gets basically it's sort of very patient
people stop motion animators that's why
I'm I've been with one for 18 years it
is it is yeah so yeah so I'm sure you
this is not new to you then you've
probably had this discussion you know
over the uh lazy joke
um but the um the
something that they made me realize that
was really Innovative about that film
and like made it such a
um uh uh uh like ambitious undertaking
was that so they said something like 80
percent of the shots the camera is
moving
um so it wasn't just it made me
appreciate I just had this sudden
Epiphany where I go I can't believe I've
never appreciated that about that film
no wonder it holds up and it's so
cinematic is there they had to
computerize the technology was just
barely there enough to computerize
tracking the camera move as you like
rainbow frame yeah that because they
were showing how the props that also
required the props you know usually like
whatever's off screen they don't make
look good as you know the moment you
look around to the back side it looks
like ass they go these we had to more
completely build because the camera is
rotating around the property it's just
like it's amazing when you see them
setting up as well I've been very lucky
this is one of the many perks of um
being in a relationship with someone
who's uh so she's now a department head
at Leica who are
world-class Best in Class like they are
incredible like they're taking exactly
what you're talking about and kind of
taking to the next level now
um but yeah walking around being able to
visit all these these stages and just
the the uh the scale they have to do now
like because essentially like you say
they set a Preston with moment
yeah well I just I went to um she was
working on um Pirates and Adventure with
Scientists which is a really good
stop-motion film that didn't really blow
up some pirates in an Adventure with
Scientists it's a back on the subject of
titles
it's an art exact well yeah
interestingly I think that might have
been a problem for it but it was an
Oldman film so the Watson Gromit studio
and yeah she worked on that for a bit
and like they had like this entire
basically like an entire Harbor they
built and just walking around this and
even though you know the figures are for
that because the figures they they
obviously have different scales of all
the characters so I think they were
pretty action figure size those those
particular puppets to that stage but
still like enormous space that I went to
the stage for um Missing Link and they
made like a forest because they needed
that for that it was missing links
I didn't realize that again that's the
thing with Leica movies is they're so
beautiful and so precise like the
Artistry of that team is sometimes you
you could be forgiven for not realizing
their stop-motion yeah they're
incredible I I yeah I remember seeing
the posters for that and I never I never
saw it but
Pirates Beautiful film pirates in an
Adventure with Scientists
um
I am not all I found on IMDb the thing
you'll know from about TV special about
it
the thing you would remember from that
is there's a meme of a monkey holding up
a sign like an animated gif and that's
from that is
being a different name I apologize it
was called band of Misfits okay here
it's band of Misfits yeah the book is
sorry the book upon which it's it's
based is perfect so this is one of those
uh
like the Philosopher's Stone versus the
yeah yeah yeah yeah 100 interesting I
yeah I did not know this one that's
worth the watching movie either
um
that's a beautiful film
um yeah that deserved that deserved a
bigger impact than it that had I think
looks like it made 123 million worldwide
um and it's like right at the tail end
of probably did decent DVD
uh you know so I'm sure it was by any
measure successful flop but yeah yeah I
I really rate that one I thought that
was really fun
um and Carrie worked on that you said
yeah so she worked
um she did uh what did she do on that so
she her specialism is she's she what she
at the at that on that one she was
working in the public hospital was she
won popular Hospital on that one or was
she no she was um puppet fabrication I
think so she was making she made the
hands puppet Hospital
uh after they shoot the guy sounds like
wow so these puppets are all very very
delicate yes if you're bending them
around if you think about just like a
wire toy you'd play with it snaps after
a little while right so if you think
about all the lights and the animators
moving stuff around yeah so she she the
three eyes unit for the cast yeah so she
went into that on um uh Isle of dogs
where's Anderson ah she did she went
into the public Hospital ended up by the
end of that movie running the popular
hospital or map film and now she heads
up the public department I like her
sorry about the puppy Department sorry
the public Hospital department and like
um so yeah she's she runs the team
basically running around fixing puppets
um which is fascinating because it's
every job like you have to know
literally every part of the process of
manufacturing because you have to fix
every aspect so they have to paint they
have to sculpt they have to whatever I
gotta say this was an X Factor I didn't
see coming in this episode this very
today's very special playwatch listen I
didn't here's a job I've known the
basics of what she does but the notion
of specifically the puppet hospital I
think this is the first time it's
awesome we've broached that and it's so
fantastic this is one of the things that
I just love about games and Cinema as an
art form that these very esoteric but
highly essential and specific things
emerge that well that's the fascinating
thing about her job is it's such a small
like there's only about okay about 20
people with that job like basically
running that kind of team so that's
what's interesting about like when her
job is rarer particle physicist you know
like there are a few of her than than
you know some of the the most but it's
worked out really well because I can
live anywhere for my job so I've
basically always followed her around the
various hubs where she can where she can
do this because there aren't many
stop-motion studios in the world it's a
very limited pool it's doing they're
doing quite well there's more of them
now than there was for a bit just
because of uh I think largely because
I'm like streaming services and and
stop-motion being an aesthetic but
people still kind of want well I suspect
also because
um
like even Pixar I see people more and
more I see more and more kind of tweets
and things just to give me a vague sense
of the Zeitgeist that what made that
that Pixar brand of 3D animation very
especially unique is starting to lose
some of its luster and you see more and
more appreciation for like you look at
the cartoon Saloon uh films uh like like
wolf Walkers and and song of the sea and
and you see people like just raving
about the Artistry of those films and
you see like I think that there's a I
think that there's or maybe slightly
overdosed on that specific kind of 3D
animation look and now they're looking
to go what else can we do and just in
the same way that practical models that
you film and add CG to are just
seemingly
eternally more Evergreen than the you
know the pure CGI effect shots
um it just seems like this pendulum is
kind of swinging back at least at least
somewhat
um yeah I think it goes in and out
fashion like she's been you know we both
graduated and went into our first jobs
about God like 14 years ago now and like
yeah there's definitely been ups and
downs of the industry where it's been
you know easier to get a job less easy
to get a job I'd say now seems to be
from my perspective like a bit of a boom
time there's just a lot of stuff right
you've got like elemo del Toro's new
movie Pinocchio that stop-motion you've
got
um the uh I think the director of
Nightmare Before Christmas has just done
Henry Selix just done a um uh yeah he
has some new Key and Peele movies yeah
yeah it's like a it's it's a I don't
think it's I think it's just Jordan
Peele producing
[Music]
Wendell and why I thought it was a
comedy thing that's the one yeah
um there's the thing Carrie's working on
just got announced but you're right it
is a comedy yeah actually you know what
you know what I think it's just Jordan
peel but but
key I.E Keegan Michael key is in it
that's why you right okay he's like one
of the lead voices but it is a it was
built as a Jordan peel thing and it has
that look of being like a a horror but
uh it actually is like comedy makes me
realize that I didn't know again
Wendell and wild I didn't know what to
make of it so I put all my eggs on the
key art like all my projection of the
perception of it and it looks a bit like
a potentially like viably creepy
animated
uh like it could be it's one of those
where the the look of it could swing in
the family film animation direction or
like some
interesting art style for what is
otherwise like like the Jordan peel
thing which is
legitimate kind of eerie atmospheric
genre of filmmaking
uh I think it's out soon right I think
is is it a Netflix one yeah this one
yeah I know Kerry went to the uh went to
a screening of it and I don't know if it
was the screw but went to a screening
and said it was very good nice um oh
yeah Netflix Netflix Oh in a couple
weeks yeah
but yeah it seems to be on a bit of a
Resurgence she's uh she's she's been
doing well with it for last year's yeah
well I've learned uh what a puppet
hospital is and so I think I got my
money's worth today uh
yeah I'm starting to think a bit Alana
and Troy and not joining us Austin
Troy being in a let me see a late night
time zone right now uh I believe
um said he basically he's busy he sent
me a message saying it's Last of Us
three is just it's going over a bit
how hilarious would it be if that turned
out to you didn't you couldn't possibly
have known but it's actually true yeah
uh and you're like amazing you know
Charlie desist from Sony the second this
episode comes out yeah I'm Alana also is
saying she's not she's not joining us um
so yeah fair enough she has some job
doing video games uh something about
someone's dad I don't really understand
what that is
um yeah I don't get it uh I think I just
described also the first party games
there though that's true it's a game
about someone's Dad yeah I'm the most
I'm the most free amongst the
Freelancers of this podcast actually I
think Troy and I are technically the
only like do you count as Freelancers
since you you have a lot of the benefits
of it but running a company like are you
salaried under Europe I'm a salaried
employee of Bethel games okay with
coincidence I didn't start the company
it's just called Bethel games
yeah you just you're a natural fit as a
result technically I'm a celebrity
employer as well but um but um no so
yeah I'm a PO I'm POI which means like
you know it's it's an on the books
employee standard kind of employment
contract with my company but I own that
so I wouldn't I would call myself I
don't know what what's this make me a it
makes me a business owner I guess but
like money bags Mike no freelancer money
bags Mike yeah
the only sort of traditional Freelancers
uh then and yeah yeah me and Alana work
for the man the only difference is in my
case the man is me oh you just stand in
the mirror every morning and go who's
the man I'm looking exactly I knew it uh
well then I will say I'm Austin uh
composer Mike is the man and uh this was
play watch listen goodbye bye everyone
[Music]
thank you